>>> NOW TO A CNN EXCLUSIVE.
U.S. CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF TOM
MANGER IS SPEAKING OUT FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE PAUL PELOSI
WAS ATTACKED IN THE WAKE OF THAT
DAY HE IS PAINTING A GRIM
PICTURE.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THE
THREAT LANDSCAPE RIGHT NOW
AGAINST LAWMAKERS?
>> IT'S PROBABLY AS BAD AS
PERHAPS IT'S EVER BEEN AND
CERTAINLY SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE
I'VE SEEN THE THREAT LANDSCAPE
GET MORE AND MORE SERIOUS IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBERS OF THREATS
AGAINST MEMBERS AND THE TYPES OF
THREATS, EVEN JUST THE THINGS
THAT MEMBERS ARE DEALING WITH
WHEN THEY'RE HERE, HAD THEY'RE
AT THEIR HOME DISTRICTS, SOME OF
THE THREATS THAT THEY GET, SO
JUST THE LEVEL OF HATE SPEECH,
THE LEVEL OF VIOLENCE IN OUR
COUNTRY DIRECTED TOWARD
POLITICAL OFFICIALS, GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS, IT'S REALLY AT A
POINT WHERE I THINK THAT IT'S AS
DANGEROUS AS IT'S EVER BEEN TO
BE AN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
>> DANGEROUS AS IT HAS EVER
BEEN.
THAT'S PRETTY ALARMING, ALEX.
>> IT SURE IS AND ALL THE MORE
ALARMING BECAUSE IT'S NOT
TERRIBLY SURPRISING, RIGHT?
WE'VE HEARD IT FROM MEMBERS AND
CANDIDATES THAT THE WAY THEIR
FAMILIES FEEL UNDER SIEGE, THE
THREATS THAT COME IN TO THEIR
YOUNG STAFF, JUST ABUSE POURING
IN OVER THE PHONE LINES WHEN
FEATURED ON TELEVISION PROGRAMS
OR A TARGET OF SOCIAL MEDIA
MEMBERS OF THE 1/6 COMMITTEE
THAT NEEDED POLICE STATIONED AT
THE END OF THEIR DRIVEWAY.
IT'S INCREDIBLY DARK AND, PAM,
YOU KNOW, THE THING I FIND MOST
DISQUIETING ABOUT THE WHOLE
THING, THERE'S NO REAL END IN
SIGHT, ALL RIGHT, THAT CHIEF
MAKER CAN TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
OPTIONS ARE FOR SORT OF BEEFING
SECURITY AT THE CAPITOL OR
RESPONDING MORE ASSERTIVELY TO
INDIVIDUAL THREATS AGAINST
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS BUT WE'RE
LOOKING AT A BIGGER CULTURAL
PROBLEM NOT WITHIN THE POWER OF
THE CAPITOL POLICE TO SOLVE.
>> SOMETIMES MEMBERS ARE MAKING
THE PROBLEM WORSE.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
THIS IS REALLY THE
RESPONSIBILITY SOMETIMES OF
LAWMAKERS TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING, RIGHT?
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE LISTENING TO
THEM.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING UP TO THEM.
PEOPLE TAKE CUES ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT THEY'RE TARGETING.
I THINK THAT THAT IS THE
SCARIEST PART OF THIS IS THAT IF
YOU TELL THE PUBLIC
MISINFORMATION, THEN THE PUBLIC
RECEIVES THAT INFORMATION,
STARTS TO BELIEVE IT AND IT
BECOMES REALLY HARD SOMETIMES TO
UNDO THAT.
I MEAN, I THINK JANUARY 6th IS
REALLY THE PINNACLE EXAMPLE OF
THAT, PEOPLE WERE FED LIES ABOUT
THE ELECTION BEING STOLEN AND IT
FUELED PEOPLE TO WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
PEOPLE WHO WENT INTO THE
BUILDING THAT DAY BELIEVED THAT
THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
>> THERE'S STILL SO MANY
AMERICANS WHO BELIEVE THAT.
I ACTUALLY ASKED CHIEF MANGER
ABOUT JANUARY 6th AND WHETHER HE
HAS THE RESOURCES TO PREVENT
ANOTHER INSURRECTION.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> RIGHT AFTER JANUARY 6th,
THERE WERE A FAIR NUMBER OF
AFTER ACTION REPORTS AND
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORTS THAT
LISTED ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
WENT WRONG, LISTED ALL OF THE
FAILURES THAT PEOPLE DETERMINED
OCCURRED, AND SO IT WAS REALLY A
CHECKLIST THAT WE COULD USE
TO -- AS WE STARTED TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE HOW WE WERE GOING TO
IMPROVE THINGS, IT WAS A
CHECKLIST THAT WE COULD USE TO
JUST SORT OF KNOCK IT OFF THE
THINGS WE NEEDED TO DO TO ENSURE
THAT JANUARY 6th NEVER HAPPENED
AGAIN.
>> SO CLEARLY CHANGES HAVE BEEN
MADE.
THEY WENT THROUGH THAT CHECKLIST
BUT ONLY HAVE SO MANY RESOURCES
AND THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN A THEME
COMING FROM CAPITOL POLICE.
MONEY IN THE OMNIBUS FOR THEM
BUT HE TALKED ABOUT, LOOK, IN
SOME CASES THEY'VE HAD TO
OUTSOURCE AND PUT 40 TO 50
OUTSIDE UNARMED GUARDS AT
SECONDARY POINTS OF THE CAPITOL
TO CHECK CREDENTIALS OF PEOPLE
ALREADY IN SO THAT THEY CAN MOVE
THE OFFICERS ELSEWHERE TO SECURE
IT.
>> I WAS STRUCK BY HOW THINLY
STRETCHED THEY'VE BEEN SINCE
JANUARY 6th AND FOR THOSE OF US
WHO GO IN AND OUT OF THE CAPITOL
I HAD NO IDEA THOSE FOLKS WHO
WERE MANNING THE DOORS NOW WERE
NOT SECURITY GUARDS AT THIS
POINT AND HE ALSO MENTIONED, I
THINK THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT,
THEY HAD TO PUT SO MUCH
ATTENTION ON THAT JANUARY 6th
CHECKLIST ON PROTECTING MEMBERS
THERE THAT THAT'S PARTLY HOW
THEY GOT INTO A SITUATION WHERE
THEY WEREN'T PAYING AS MUCH
ATTENTION TO GUARDING THEIR
HOMES, GUARDING THEM WHEN
THEY'RE TRAVELING AND THAT
OBVIOUSLY CAME INTO PLAY WITH
THE SITUATION WITH HOUSE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI.
>> EXACTLY.
I THINK IN MANY WAYS, YOU KNOW,
YOU COULD SAY IT WAS A WAKE-UP
CALL BECAUSE THEY HAD BEEN SO
FOCUSED ON PROTECTING THE
PERIMETER THAT YOU HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE ACCORDING TO A
LETTER FROM A HOUSE COMMITTEE
AND CHIEF MAJOR CONFIRMED THEY
HPTSDZ DONE AN ASSESSMENT OF
SPEAKER PELOSI'S RESIDENCE SINCE
SHE BECAME SPEAKER A SECOND
TIME.
THAT SAYS A LOT ABOUT HOW
ESSENTIALLY BOGGED DOWN THEY
WERE.
WE DON'T KNOW IN 2018 WHAT THEY
OFFERED IN TERMS OF SECURITY
OPTIONS, WHAT THEY SHOULD DO,
WHETHER THOSE OPTIONS WERE
APPROVED.
THERE'S STILL A LOT WE DON'T
KNOW BUT IT IS TELLING?
>> IT CERTAINLY IS.
AND THE FACT THAT WE EVEN HAVE
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW STRETCHED THIN THE CAPITOL
POLICE FORCE IS.
IF WE INCREASE THE SIZE OF THE
FORCE BY FIVE OR SIX TIMES,
SURE, THE CAPITOL WOULD BE
SAFER, THE MEMBERS WOULD BE
SAFER DAY TO DAY BUT THEN WHAT
KIND OF CONGRESS WOULD WE HAVE
AND WHAT KIND OF ABILITY FOR
MEMBERS HAVE TO INTERACT WITH
THE PUBLIC OR MEDIA.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY AT THIS
TABLE AND ALMOST SERVING ON THE
HILL WANTS TO GO BACK TO THE
DAYS OF THE CAPITOL BEING ARMED
CAMP AS IT WAS IN THE DAYS AFTER
JANUARY 6th.
BUT, YOU KNOW, GOD, IF THERE'S
NOT SOME KIND OF BIGGER CHANGE
IN THE WAY OUR CULTURE INTERACTS
WITH OUR POLITICS, THAT MAY JUST
BE WHERE WE END UP HEADED.
>> EXACTLY.
AND, YOU KNOW, I ASKED HIM ABOUT
WHAT KEVIN McCARTHY HAS SAID
THAT, LOOK, THIS IS ABOUT
MANAGEMENT, NOT ADDING MORE
PEOPLE.
HE'S INDICATED HE WANTS THE
MAGNETOMETERS TO BE TAKEN DOWN
THAT WERE PUT UP.
THEY PUT IT UP.
THEY CAN TAKE IT DOWN, CHIEF
MANGER SAID.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ADVICE ON
HOW TO DO MY JOB.
HE'S IN NO EASY POSITION.
>> WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THESE MEMBERS ARE AT THE
CAPITOL MAYBE MONDAY THROUGH
THURSDAY OR MONDAY THROUGH
FRIDAY, BUT THEN THEY GO HOME
AND PROTECTING SOMEONE IN THEIR
DISTRICT IS A WHOLE OTHER
CHALLENGE THAT IS I DO NOT ENVY
HIM FOR HAVING TO FIGURE OUT.
>> HE COULDN'T GET INTO
SPECIFICS BUT IT'S CLEAR THEY'RE
LOOKING HARD ON HOW TO BEEF UP
SECURITY FOR MEMBERS WHEN
THEY'RE IN WASHINGTON BUT ALSO
THE RESIDENCES AND FAMILY
MEMBERS IN THE RESIDENCES WHEN
THEY'RE NOT THERE SO REALLY
INTERESTING ANALYSIS.